You are listening to radiolab radio
from
W N Y s t e n n p.
R. A M. Jad Abumrad.
I'm Robert Krulwich. This is radio lab. And today we're talking about,
I don't think they'll ever be another specimen that'll be exactly like that.
This one actually, uh, our,
our next podcast is a full hour about stories that grow out of particular
things, objects. But today we have a preview. Yes. Sort of. So that's the place,
right? This is the place to story about a thing. So in this spot,
it lives inside a steel vault.
Inside this huge laboratory at wits university in Johannesburg,
South Africa. We asked a professor there,
Dr. Bernard does that fail to pull it out and show it to our reporter,
Patricia Hume. And this is the originals.
This is it.
[inaudible]
this. We have a dry in front of us here. I mean, I, I handle this a lot,
but like it gets fresh every time I take this out.
The reason it gives him goose flesh goosebumps is because this object seems to
completely up. And two basic questions about, you know, human history.
It's amazing. Where did we begin and when we began,
who was trying to take us out?
[inaudible]
pretty sure Andy Mills takes this story from here, right,
with thunder and vigor and Gusto with Gusto. Yes. I'd like to with Gusto please.
All right. Look,
it's one of those discoveries that almost didn't happen and here to help me tell
you the story. Okay. I'm professor Lee Berger is Lee.
I am a research professor at the University of Witwatersrand in Johannesburg and
an explorer in residence at the National Geographic Society and explore in
residence. That's a weird title. It seems like it should be one or the other.
It's almost an oxymoron, isn't it? Yeah.
Lee's says that our story begins back in the 1920s in South Africa at a place
called Tongue Tang.
It's t a n u g town is the proper thing in Swana,
the western way of saying his tongue.
It's a desert area on the southern edge of the Kalahari escarpment.
Kind of like your stereotypical picture of Africa, red rocks, Bale, Bob trees,
roaming gazelles,
and back in the 1920s the place was crawling with Europeans digging mines.
You say we're blasting away with, with with dynamite drilling,
with big steam drills and huge explosions would take places.
And one day these miners,
they're blowing their way through a bit of this hillside and
yeah,
as the rock falls away and the smoke clears,
they realize that they've opened up this cave, an ancient cave,
and inside of that cave we found dozens of these strange looking rocks,
almost like animal bones. One of the minors. He takes those bones,
give them to a geologists, geologist, box them up,
and sent them to this Australian guy who was living Johannesburg named Raymond
Dart. And that's probably the first miracle in this story.
Raymond Dart was a neuro anatomist, a comparative neuroanatomists,
one of the only ones in the world.
This was the guy who knew his fossils and when this box arrived,
he was actually wearing a three piece suit.
He's going to be best man at a wedding, in fact, later that afternoon.
But he's like, that can wait. So he reached into the box,
shuffled through some antelope scope. It was full of the boon skulls, monkey,
Scholes, until he got to this one rock. Now to you or me,
this would've just looked like a big chunk of limestone,
but Raymond ARD immediately realized that he had something special and he
started,
he actually went and got his wife knitting needles and started scratching away
at this rock, much to his wife's disgust.
He then spent the next several months delicately chipping away at the limestone
until the rock literally caught free and there he stared
into a perfect little face.
You can see here the face is quite flat and then human life
lot like the face of a child, a human child,
but humans have a larger brain according to doctors that felt this child's brain
was smaller than the human child. It was closer to the size of a chimpanzee,
so it had features of a human. It had a brain more like a chimpanzees stranger,
still dark, who remember study, this sort of thing.
He looked at the foramen magnum.
That's the hole in the base of your skull where your spine goes in.
He knew that for creatures that walk on four legs,
that hole is generally towards the back of the skull so they can look forward.
But here the holes on the bottom,
which suggested to them that this creature locked up, right?
[inaudible]
it was not a monkey. It wasn't an ape. As we know apes today,
it was certainly not a modern human being. This was something in between.
If you were walking across a broken woodland where little Tom Chow might've
lived, you would've seen a a person.
Often the distance as you approached though,
you'd begin to see that something was wrong with the proportions.
Arms were probably a little longer legs, a little bit shorter.
The head was too small and as you stepped closer,
you'd see the Little Tome child's body would have been covered in this thick
hair, potentially even for more like an ape than than we have,
but it'd be like no AP you've ever seen because it would be standing there in
very much the way you would be standing staring at it
on two legs. So if, if,
if this is a little bit human and a little bit apes sort of kind of in the
middle it seems, did he, did he feel like this was the quote missing link?
We don't use that term because evolution doesn't happen that way,
but it's certainly dark.
Did he even fact wrote a book called adventures with the missing link and right
after he discovered the skull,
he sent a paper off an amazing speed of journal Nature.
It was published in February of 1925 he thought that was going to revolutionize
everything,
but he was whole heartedly rejected by the great scientific community of Europe
for two reasons. First, we already knew that humans didn't evolve in Africa.
Yeah, Africa was backward. That was the belief says Chris Stringer,
I'm a research leader in human origins at the Natural History Museum in London
and he explained that back in the early 20th century,
people of the time felt that if you look in Europe,
you can see all this wonderful Kayvon painted many thousands of years ago.
They prefer to think that you are at war Asia will more likely centers of our
origins than Africa was. Second,
scientists already found a skull that they believed belonged to.
The quote unquote missing link was something called Piltdown man.
It was this ancient man fossil thing that they found in a golf course in
England. So in their minds, that was the right place. Then also compute down,
man,
you've got this very large brain and a brain case that looks really quite like a
modern human one, which made sense to them. You know,
clearly European ancestors would have had big brains,
but because they're European. Yeah,
I mean the tooling individual had a small brain way too small.
This thing was too primitive. It didn't look right. So dark.
He spent the next 20 plus years arguing,
look, people,
this is our ancestor and getting nowhere until in the late 1920s other fossils
started showing up in China, South Africa, Kenya, Ethiopia,
and these other fossils.
They were from roughly the same era as the Piltdown man, but their brains,
their teeth, their bone structures, they were all totally different.
So this was very weird. I mean, you know, how do you explain that for decades?
Nothing else, not Piltdown man turns up from anywhere in the world.
So some forensic experts at the London Museum of natural history,
they decide maybe we ought to go take a closer look at Piltdown.
Man by started looking at the material under the microscopes and right off the
bat they found that one of the teeth clearly showed the marks of a metal file,
that it had been filed down to look flat.
No built down was a fraud,
was a fake of forgery, a hoax, and the holsters were never caught.
They were questions in the houses of parliament about the competence of the
Natural History Museum.
That is that each experts had been fought for all this time cause this wasn't
even a very good fake. They had taken the jawbone of an orangutan.
They took some modern human skull pieces. They then stained that material,
dark brown, so it looked the same color,
no even fake stone tools and all this time right there in front of them was the
tongue child.
Aw.
It is estimated as purely an estimate of being around 2 million,
2.2 million years old, which still today is the oldest,
not quite yet human fossil that we this, this
would be probably the greatest or one of the greatest discoveries ever been
argued to be the most important single fossil ever discovered in the history of
humankind.
Search for ancestry because it brought to the fall that humanity originated in
Africa that every human on earth is an African,
we are all of African origin
but but more than just where we came from,
which I think is totally cool. Yeah. Huh. Super interesting. We can,
we can look at the skull and we can see things about, you know,
what life was like for this like little version of us that lived so long ago.
We look at the teeth and we can see what it was eating.
Was it eating like what we eat?
It's teeth are like surprisingly similar to our teeth. So yeah, it wasn't,
it wasn't like hugely different from what we eat.
But I think the most exciting thing that it can tell us is, you know,
not just about what our life was like,
but what was lurking in the shadows waiting to take us out.
You can tell that from this school, I mean this, this skull is, it's,
it's kind of at the center of this murder mystery. I,
he who killed the tongue job at the time when, when,
when Raymond dark made that discovery,
he had this sort of gut feeling that this tone child was killed by one of its
own. You know, cause this is like 1924 we were between two wars,
world war one had occurred with the horrible destruction.
Dart was actually a medic in that war and he walked away,
convinced the humans were,
we're inherently evil creatures that were inherently violent and that we were
probably a lot worse in the past. And in fact,
the opening of 2001 a space odyssey
where you see the monkeys kind of like beating each other with the bones was
based on Raymond Darts,
theories of the violent origins on the continent of Africa.
So
that was darts like pet theory that maybe Tom got clubbed down by his brother or
his neighbor.
But that ignores one big thing in that limestone mine where the tongue skull was
found. There were also all these other skulls, baboons schools, monkey skulls.
There was this like little collection of bones where like what you would expect
to find in a Predator stun. So not a tongue like creature, but yeah,
maybe the cat big cat,
at least a large man alien predator. Then because that's perfectly acceptable.
If we're tough, they're tough.
It's okay to be killed by something mean and vicious.
So that became the new theory because what else do humans have to fear? Right?
Well what now here's where I think maybe you come into this story for some
reason, when you arrive many, many, many years later,
this idea that the cat did,
it seems to disturb you. I was addicted to that
story. Is anyone else?
I'd been brought up on it through my anthropology classes. Every,
every book I ever read said that. But one day in,
in 1994 he bumps into a completely new idea.
In it in an almost Eureka moment
[inaudible]
cause they're, I was at Gladys fail an excavation site in South Africa.
Lee and his team were doing what they do, digging for fossils.
I just finished excavation.
All my team had left and I was sitting there watching the sunset and I looked up
on the hillside
and there was a troop of vervet monkeys or a small gray monkey and they were
coming down to forge down the hill and all of a sudden I heard an alarm
and I looked up in the sky and there came a huge eagle.
The monkeys scattered as this eagle swooped around the edge of the hill and as
it came down around the edge of the hill,
I realized it was a trap because coming around the other edge of the hill was
that Eagle's mate and it zoomed in and whacked one of those large muscles right
in front of me and everything went silent.
The other Eagle landed this eagle sitting on top of a now dead monkey and the
eagle staring at me, I'm staring at it probably with my mouth open.
It looks at me for a moment and then leaps off the edge of this cliff with this
dead monkey and flies away with it down the valley.
And I had an idea. So I got into my car,
I chased the direction it went. I knew where it was going.
I knew where these Black Eagle Nest, where they were up on a cliff face.
I crawled up under crossing a river,
crawled up under the the nest and there was this pile of bones,
huge pile of bones, high racks, his little antelopes, a baboon skull,
a baby baboon skull,
and almost every one of the bones there had these amazing ah marks on them.
Key shape cuts where the eagles have driven their talons into the skulls.
These big eagles can have killing talents at five, six, seven inches long.
If you can imagine that I got in my car back to the lab and Joe Burke,
he whips open the drawer that contains those skulls and bones that were found
with the tone child skull and okay,
exact same marks, couldn't believe it.
There's even like a little mark on the tongue child skull itself.
A year later, 1995 he and a colleague, they publish a paper,
Bernadette blamed eagles for the death of the Tom Child and it was received like
a smelly, wet blanket by the field. Why? Why would, why would you,
why would they not say, oh, of course.
Because it was entrenched idea. You know,
lease says maybe subconsciously they felt like our ancestors are being demoted
again. That is that, you know,
we were not the masters of our universe because cats just feel tougher than
birds, I don't know. But according to leave, the big cat scientists were like,
you know, it's been published.
It's been published to leopard did it for 40 years.
We even got into a debate in the,
in the hallowed pages of the journal Nature One,
the load lifting capacity of birds of prey on whether or not birds of prey could
lift something as large as the tongue job and these debates they went on for
years.
He couldn't convince people we needed something more until one night it was
about nine o'clock at night. Years later it was at home.
Seeing in my little study,
he was reading an academic paper about eagles and how eagles sometimes when they
kill a little mammals,
they'll reach into their ice sockets and pluck out their eyes to get it.
The knife, juicy brain on the inside.
And in the paper it was this really beautiful image. Well,
it's beautiful to people who study dead things,
but a beautiful image of a skull,
of a primate with the interior sockets of eyes with these jacket marks in it.
These very particular scratch marks on the underside of the ice sockets.
And I was staring at these images and I went, okay,
[inaudible]
oh my goodness. Or something to that effect.
I got into my car, drove down to the lab, opened up the safe,
pulled out the tongue child, turn the face over.
And there they were
[inaudible]
on the base of the inside of the ice socket where these jagged rigid marks that
that you had to have done by reaching into the orbit,
the exact same marks.
You can see little squiggle marks on the spike. Little, uh,
exclamation marks, a little calmers. No one had noticed that before.
And Imagine I'm sitting in the middle of this anatomy department in the middle
of the night in a vault containing million year old fossil.
It was a magic moment. It was fantastic. All right,
so now you know a little bit about how this creature lived and how it died.
I mean, beyond solving the murder mystery, what does that tell you? Well,
first to say,
solving the murder mystery is kind of cool and that's always a neat thing and
there's nothing wrong with just doing that, but have you ever thought,
why when you're standing out on a playground or standing out in an open field
and a shadow passes over you,
do you know that feeling that occurred,
whether it be from an airplane or whatever?
First you get that tingly feel on the back of your neck and then you yank your
head up. You ever wondered why you do that? Yeah,
you do that because the little tongue child died two and a half million years
ago because he didn't look up quick enough when that happened.
But is there any meals? One thing we should say.
One very important thing we should say is actually we did an experiment with the
story.
We hooked up with some people at Makerbot and some very nice folks at the field
museum in Chicago and we had a three d scans made of the tongue skull.
I'm actually holding one right now. We do. Yeah. Mine's purple. Mine's pink.
Why is pink? I don't know if that was the color of the plastic days.
These are amazing replicas of the tongue child, skull.
I mean you can see all the ridges. You can feel the scratches and the eyes.
Imagine if you could listen to the story you just heard while holding the tongue
child in your head. Well that's exactly the reason we did this.
We have partnered with a museum called museum that's a spelled with four m's,
two in the front, two in the back, a museum.
It's this tiny little elevator shaft size place here in Manhattan where they
display all these sort of like oddities, you know,
like little objects from Saddam Hussein's palace. Uh,
we have a pool toys that were banned from Saudi Arabia. Right.
And they will also be displaying our 3d replica of the Tang skull.
So if you go there, you can actually hold the skull,
you dial in a little number,
and you can hear part of the piece while you're standing there. Yeah,
and I gotta tell you,
it's a very different experience to listen to the story while holding this
thing. And not only that,
if you have a three d printer of your own and you go to radio lab.org,
you can download a scan, a three d scan of the tongue skull,
and you can print your own.
Thanks again to makerbot and to shoot digital for helping to make that happen.
Props to Lynn Levy for conceiving of the whole idea. Go to our website,
radiolab.org I'm Jad Abumrad. I remember privilege. Thanks for listening.